were you the popular girl in high school
no no no I was really I didn't get it
together and are you gonna go have
plastic surgery and stuff yeah what are
you gonna do it yourself you know face
stuff Robin could I take a good look at
you do you mind wait a second let me
take a good look at you
face stop what would you do to this face
the this is the thing everyone whose
face you like every celebrity that
you're like they're naturally beautiful
they've all had stuff done so just like
a friend of mine a woman I know and what
she always tells me that I go no they
have everyone I think I might get my
lips done next week that's the cool
thing the lip thing it's not permanent
I'm gonna just get the one that's like
laughs pump it up a little it's a little
plump I got it I must listen lip [ __ ]
talk to me
you're good-looking girl nothing wrong
with you don't plump your lips okay
you're gonna look ridiculous
you don't look like a [ __ ] clown then
you're gonna go and then you're gonna do
a roast anyone's gonna look at this
[ __ ] girl good-looking girl impress
any guy who doesn't deal with guys and
you know what they're not good enough
for you I'm canceling my appointment
thank you that's all I needed to hear
what do you think it would do to have
this plastic surgery what's gonna happen
exactly I just went I don't know what it
is it's just like I once I put a lot of
value on looks and I wish I didn't and I
know you look at me I'm a mess okay
that's not true it well but I need to
kind but you know I know what I know
what the score is
you know what I mean if you saw yourself
the way we all see and I relate to this
because I'm not a good-looking guy I
know that and I've accepted it now you
are an attractive woman but you know
what it is Howard when you take a look
better when you take no now stop it when
you take off your clothes when you do
you like what you see in the mirror yeah
yeah you got a nice body
yeah facially beautiful nose hair the
whole lips are not teeth are nice did
you wear braces when you were kids yeah
yeah I can see you got strained them got
a great nose you got a you got a snap
out of this well yeah if you got your
ass can I get it can I get some
injections in my butt you're thinking of
butt injections
you know when girls get breast implants
in their subtle a pickup
put in their silicone in whatever they
put in then alone you look good all
right I needed to I needed to talk to
you about this stuff because really the
guy falls in love with your ass after
you put that in it exactly what why he's
not yeah I know that I know that you
know and guys ain't looking to you
they're looking at your titties they're
looking at the hair they're looking at
the legs I don't look anybody's ass
nobody's gonna see my ass it's that's
the way it goes